foreign
I can't help it I'm still fettling with
this deck
I've done this versions of this talk now
since since 2019 because I was thinking
hey it's coming into the 2020s I should
be sort of looking forward like this
would be a fun talk to do
and the podcasts help all of that you
know they upside to making any gotnet
rocks listeners a few in the room
excellent so you know I it's an
interview I interview every week I get a
chance to talk to a lot of luminaries
and you know you sort of get a sense of
the Gestalt of what people are working
on admittedly with uh Microsoft bias you
know to be honest.net rocks is for.net
developers now not everything that.net
developers do has to be Microsoft based
but a lot of it is running as radio is
more on the I.T side it definitely got a
Microsoft bias as well
but when you try to look forward out 10
years that's pretty hard you know uh
Niels Bohr has did the is the original
originator this quote the prediction is
difficult especially about the future I
don't know what else you'd predict but
yeah it's gonna be difficult
but when we're talking about software
we're always we have to talk about the
hardware the platforms that it run on
that really is what dictates us
logically software Trails Hardware so
what I want to predict the future and
I'm very much a believer in in William
Gibson's statement the future is here
it's just not evenly distributed
so you can go into spots out in the
world where they are pressing against
the edge of things like how will that
expand how will that cover more things
you know the Cloud's not a big
innovation now we're pretty comfortable
with it being around and if you're going
to stick around tonight I'm going to
tell a early Cloud story as uh what as
part of the evening's festivities
insanely important this is a new utility
we only have a few Utilities in
Civilization right clean water sewage
systems electricity
internet connectivity
telephone you know those are utilities
and now with through because of the
internet we also have the opportunity to
have compute on demand you know you open
the tap and bits come out
and it's that combination of cloud and
the smartphone that has really shaped
Society for the past decade or so has
changed a lot of things mostly we've
generated a tremendous amount of data
ourselves about ourselves that lots of
people are exploiting
uh and I think we're at a turning point
on all of that as well but that's not
necessarily a software problem per se
and none of this is any prediction these
are logical Trends more compute more
devices more data that's pretty
predictable but if you actually get to
think about what's going to change in
the next decade what's going to be
different in that time
well then there's a few more interesting
things one of them is Moore's law is
going to end now Gordon Moore is one of
the principals at Intel back in the day
uh when Intel spun off from Fairchild
semiconductor their first business was
making semiconductor Ram now this is in
the 1960s when a lot of storage was
actually done with Ferris cores wound
with copper wire so a semiconductor
storage thing was a big deal the CPU
comes later not until 1970 they built
the 4004.
and so this observation that Gordon
Moore made
was really about Ram it was that hey for
the same amount of money we can double
the number of transistors on a given
piece of silicon
every 18 to 24 months
essentially what he said it's hardly a
law because you know laws are things
that happen whether you want them to or
not gravity is a law you really don't
have a choice on that one
right the reality of that statement was
if a large group of people work
extremely hard we can double the number
of transistors roughly for the same
production cost
and that trend has continued
up until now so if I pull the data set
of CPU performance from Wikipedia I get
a graph like this literally from 1970
from the original 4004 up to current
generation processors with a geometry
scale on the left side
uh we get a pretty good line now if I
only went up incrementally this graph
looks more like the hockey stick because
the numbers jump so radically as they
keep on doubling and it's hard to get
your head around billions of transistors
and the fact that we've continued this
trend for so long the fun way I like to
describe it is to show you one of these
what's this warp drive from the
Enterprise nope nope that's this
uh this is a cray 2 supercomputer
and in 1985 this was the computer of
choice if you had 16 million dollars
burning a hole in your pocket and about
200 kilowatts of power you could have
one of these super computers there was
only a few hundred ever made they were
typically products for governments and
universities and they modeled nuclear
explosions on they helped calculate some
of the satellite trajectories for the
great exploration exploration satellites
and it had about 1.9 gigaflops of
processing power 1.9 billion floating
Point operations per second
1985. fast forward a few years to 2011
the iPad 2 about 800 bucks
um battery operated also has 1.9
gigaflops of processing power
and you play Candy Crush on it
you give it to children
and let's face it that's 2011. that's
not fast
you know what's fast today
well arguably the fastest piece of com
of consumer computer equipment would be
than Nvidia RTX 4090.
okay if you can find one and they're
coming in around like two grand like
that's a lot of money 400 450 watts of
power so hope you got the big power
supply and a lot of extra fans
uh 82 teraflops
so 40
000 times faster than that iPad 2.
that's a lot of Candy Crush
and of course that's just a consumer
product right in theory we can buy this
at the local store when you talk about
the most powerful computers in the world
there's been a race going on for some
time between the Japanese the Chinese
and the Americans to build super
computers the current leader at the
moment is Japan's uh fugaku
supercomputer that's about 7.3 million
cores uh 29 megawatts of electricity so
bring your own nuclear reactor
uh
200 and it comes in at about 415
petaflops flat out
so 220 million times faster than the
iPad 2. Moore's Law right that as we can
keep harnessing more and more compute by
the way about a billion dollars so if
you're trying to pick between the
supercomputer or the B2 bomber
if you can get one of these
they're of course exactly only one of
these and that's as many as we need
right there's only so many problems this
computer can actually do that's
meaningful uh
it models airflow simulations across
airfoils it's the reason that hurricane
and typhoon prediction is so accurate
these days these kinds of machines do
that work very complex modeling it's not
a normal set of problems they're a
narrow space to operate in
but we were talking about Moore's Law
right that way that this is going to end
that we can't just keep going this way
now why why would this end it's been fun
okay our careers you know 50 60 years of
just you're always going to get more
compute we don't have to make our
software all that efficient we're going
to get more compute
we're running out of silicon not
actually physically but literally the
space so the current sort of
state-of-the-art process is somewhere
around five nanometers
right again a nanometer is an impossible
thing it's a billionth of a meter like
how do you express a billionth of a
meter to someone and one of the ways I
do it is say Okay imagine
I want you to wait
for a second that's pretty easy what if
I actually wait for a million seconds
how long are you waiting for million
seconds it's like 11 and a half days
so you know get a coffee
what if I ask you to wait for a billion
seconds well that's 33 years
so a second is to a nanometer as 33
years is to a meter
right that's the crazy thing these are
really really small numbers it is hard
to conceive of a nanosecond it is hard
to conceive of a nanometer
but the question you have to ask
yourself like this this is the IBM
um five nanometer process so each one of
those cells is about five nanometers
across here's an electron tunneling
microscope image of a silicon substrate
so the yellow bumps you're looking at
silicon atoms
the blue gaps are the boron in the in
the substrate that makes it a
semiconductor
when you're down to five nanometers a
silicon atom is 111 picometers across or
about 0.1 nanometers
so you're talking in the neighborhood of
40 atoms across
for a transistor it's just not a lot of
atoms
so we're kind of getting to a point
where you're running out of enough atoms
to actually act as a semiconductor it
cannot continue now there's some cool
experiments going on with single atom
transition so forth but remember the
other part of Moore's Law which was
with some effort for the same amount of
money we can double the number of
transistors on a piece of substrate
right and so most of the techniques
we're looking at Beyond this
get really complicated it's not that you
have to make a transistor it's that you
need to make tens of billions of them
for about a thousand bucks
retail with profit margin
so we've had an extraordinary run of
this iteration and it cannot continue
and that's okay because it's its own
problem too because we've always had
more compute coming we kind of not fix
some things
you know the Intel Boys still have the
same set of instructions in their CPU
that they put in in 1984.
every time they try to make a new
process it didn't follow that
instruction set we wouldn't buy it
because carrying software forward is
important
and so the big thing you're going to see
as the Moore's Law stops iterating is
that we'll start changing architecture
so the that Intel architecture has just
been built on and built on and built on
since the 1980s and so it's really quite
complicated
is already being superseded by simple
architectures like arm arm was designed
much later and with a broader thinking
about what modern processors looked like
that was more inherently parallel that
mindset lends itself to a lot of
efficiency
you move electrons a lot less distance
in an arm processor than you do in an
Intel processor just because of that
compatibility package and I think we're
going to see more of that and you've
seen it already if you've looked at an
M1 processor and now the M2 what Apple's
done there by unifying modern processor
design with modern GPU design with some
interesting other calculation engines
and RAM all in a single package is
arguably the best compute device we have
right now I am stunned at how good an
iPad Pro is
uh with the M1 it's an Extraordinary
Machine and we're kind of getting this
efficiency which is not in our nature as
computer people remember we used to care
how many gigahertz were in our machines
used to they used to Market on that used
to be because all the machines were
beige it's like look they're all equally
ugly but this has more gigahertz right
that's how they sold it today actually
the machine is beautiful and you
couldn't care less how many gigahertz
and it doesn't really matter and besides
you're not out of processing power
you're out of bandwidth
speaking of bandwidth everybody really
excited about 5G
did you oh boy well somebody was at one
point you know we were lots to talk
about it we were using it today and in
the end when it comes to wireless and
this is another primary constraint that
we have if you want to move more data in
a given amount of time you have to go
higher frequency
right so we were happy living in our 4G
land at a frequency typically this
there's variations in country to Country
and different rules of around two
gigahertz the microwave frequency range
5G goes up as high as 20 gigahertz so it
can pack a lot more data without a doubt
the problem is as the frequency goes up
the penetration ability goes down if you
are old enough to remember like 2G and
3G I mean you could be sitting in a
concrete bunker and still get a call not
so much with 4G you kind of need a
pretty clear shot wooden walls is fine
anything with stone or concrete you
probably didn't get signal 5G has
problems with things like leaves
no people
I did we did a demonstration we were set
we were literally in visual view of a 5G
Tower holding the phone looking at the
we had a signal monitor on and I just
turned around and apparently I'm a
signal blocker
so uh 5G is great in the sense that it
has the potential to move a lot more
data but it's much more sensitive to the
bandwidth the architecture also allows
for much smaller Celsius we have far
more devices like they're doing some
useful things there's a 6G in the works
uh but we're continuing to struggle with
with the wireless that this is the
challenge of what do we do to maintain
connectivity for more and more and more
devices and I know I'm in Australia so
of course you guys all love starlink
because you're a big country with a lot
of open space and not a lot of cables
running all those spots I mean if you're
in the city it's fine gigabit fiber is
always going to be better I have a place
in the city that can't get gigabit fiber
but it's on hey yay for cable modems uh
but we also have a place up by the ocean
where you don't get anything let's start
and we use starlink it's starlinks good
enough it's decent and doesn't depend on
a lot of other things
they're continuing to expand it and
Theory will get faster now he's dealing
with the problem that more and more
people are using it and it's actually
consuming it's the bandwidth limits of
its satellites interesting problem and I
bring those pieces together this more
and more compute and smaller and smaller
packages and better Communications
because we are talking in the uh in this
idea of ubiquitous Computing that
Once Upon a Time these machines were
large and discreet and expensive they
had names
we cared about them and now we're
finding Computing everything
it's just it's easier for a general
purpose Computing to be a standardized
device that's easy to program by any of
us so we're naturally going to be
surrounded by more and more Computing
devices we're seeing it happen now your
appliances are getting smarter
I mean I don't say they're doing it well
because it turns out software is hard
but they have the compute power and that
opens the door for a lot of
possibilities and that is an interesting
change over the next few years is that
we're just going to have to deal with we
have many more compute devices around us
and our contexts are going to matter our
ability to move our identity into a
device do some work with it based on
access to our information and then leave
that device we're still not good at that
part but we're going to need to be it's
a ton of work
now I'd be remiss if I didn't talk a
little bit about the pandemic just
because it's been exciting for the past
couple of years is last time I was here
in this room was 2019.
and glad to be back but I don't know
what you did for the past two three
years but I hung around home quite a bit
uh our friend sat inadella said that
in the early parts of 2020
two years of cloud migration happened in
two months as everybody had to suddenly
work from home a whole lot of action
went on I'm looking forward to the
historical analysis of those early
months of 2020 and I just I'm kind of
staggered that the internet survived
remember when the EU asked Netflix to
turn off 4K mode
I think that's how close we were
that they we were just running up
everybody needed a lot of bandwidth all
at once and we were running low and same
with the cloud Hardware you've seen
already some constraints where the the
big providers have left old machines
continue to run while they're adding new
machines as quickly as they can and
capacities are kind of at the limit
so we accelerated a bunch of things now
I'm probably amongst some group of
people that were not as
um affected by the pandemic in a lot of
ways we were working from home before it
was cool right it was already a normal
part of our job and we watched everybody
else learn how to talk on video cameras
but we didn't have a big problem with it
and that part's starting to subside you
know we're getting past these elements
and I think we're all a little sick what
I find fascinating is I think virtually
every person involved in technology in
the past two years
actually hit a limit on how much screen
time they could stand I didn't think I
had a limit but I found out I find one
like a year and a half ago I'm like you
know what I really don't need to do look
at any more screens
uh the bigger impact was the efforts to
defeat this illness and sort of keep our
society together has spent a tremendous
amount of money it's disrupted Supply
chains and we are having economic
challenges and so we're seeing the shape
of the downturn now there's a bunch of
reasons we could talk about whether
we're doing dealing with it well or
dealing with poorly but we can't ignore
the truth and again the good news is
we're in Computing we're a pretty
efficient industry all in all and we can
benefit and be helpful through these
kinds of crises but we haven't had one
in a long time there's a lot of folks
who
have had a career in Computing that was
only growth that things just kept
getting bigger and bigger bigger now I
started writing code to pay my rent in
the early 80s during recession times and
that was a time when we talked a lot
about return on investment
that the way we talked about writing
software was how it would increase the
efficiency of the business
all right this was a time when there was
problems with finding workers and so the
fact that we could automate some tasks
so that one person could do more was
considered a huge feature and so it's
how I sold a lot of software and I bring
it up for all of you just to say if you
haven't thought about this
it's probably a good time to do so the
question that I asked first and foremost
is do you know how your company makes
money because rarely in our role are we
responsible for that typically we are
building tools that allow others in the
company to generate money so it's useful
for you to be aware of how that works
and make sure you're contributing to
that because there's plenty of
development projects out there that
don't tie directly to income for a
company and those are typically the
projects that get cut when things get
tight
so if you focus on projects you know
help your company be successful you're
going to stay busy and help the company
just at the right time the right way so
it's it's worth considering again it
hasn't been a big issue for a long time
but it sure is right now and it may get
bigger before we get through this
particular incident
all right
fewer broad Strokes let's talk about
known technology stuff we care about
I don't see browsers going anywhere
the browser is kind of the de facto
client these days right one would even
call them the smart clients I've got I
live enough time in the I.T side of
things to say why do I like browsers
because it's a security context I
understand and trust it's already on all
the devices I don't have to install
thing on the device
all of that internal software that my
company needs can come through those
browsers contexts that's sufficient it's
safe
it gets rid of a lot of those install
problems and so you know that dominance
is going to stick around for a long time
how you build software for your browser
that's only continuing to broaden I
grabbed a set of icons off the internet
you know so probably recognize some of
these Frameworks if we wait a minute
there'll be another one
uh and it's interesting to think about
you know how mature these are how stable
these are how well supported they are
that you can bet on software that your
company's very likely to run for a long
time
not that it just because there's a new
version of angular coming means that the
old version of angular stops working I
still know there's some 1.1 people out
there that are happy
they don't care that we're on what is it
14.
close enough
uh I also think the progressive web app
is an excellent addition to that because
it allows regular users to forget
they're using a browser at all we gave
them an icon that's the important part
we gave them ubiquitous connectivity
because disconnected clients aren't any
fun
but we can
fake pretty app-like behaviors with some
of the pwa features and we've got Mr
Sanderson around here somewhere he hates
it when I show his face on the screen
but of course he's the one in the
Microsoft world that put that did an
implementation of C sharp in webassembly
and brought us Blazer there are some
serious Blazer fans out there mostly
folks that have been doing web
development for a while in the Microsoft
community and find this very
approachable but let's face it what
webassemblies really brought us is that
equal footing for other languages to
work against the browser context and
that just opens the door to browsers
continue to dominate further
it doesn't mean there isn't an effort
for other clients and I'll talk about
that in a bit but he can't argue with if
you're writing code for our companies in
an awful lot of circumstances that's an
easy way to go
uh I gotta talk about web 3 even if I
only make fun of it
uh of course they're playing off the web
2 which was sort of the web that
appeared post the.com bust in 2000 2001
that was kind of web one I look at web
one was when we when your web server was
under your desk
web 2 was when your web server was
Facebook
right and now web 3 really speaks to
this idea of getting to decentralized
again
now it doesn't mean I want to go back to
the server underneath my desk it means
that I don't want everything behind a
Walled Garden I want a little more
control and context probably means I'm
running in the cloud uh I hear lots of
pro-web three people talking about
decentralized networking while also
saying and you have to use my server
which seems like a conflict of interest
so
I'm pretty skeptical of what's going on
but I'm kind of breaking out the pieces
and saying okay
decentralization seems like a good idea
and it's something we can do it has
distinct benefits we just have to figure
out right ways to go about it I don't
have a whole lot of problem with
blockchain I think blockchain's biggest
problem is it's associated with crypto
and crypto I got problems with but I see
blockchain in the same relationship with
crypto as I saw a bit Torrance
relationship with Napster right Napster
was actually a criminal Enterprise that
dependent on BitTorrent to distribute
music and
blockchains pretty much in the same boat
an awful lot of crypto is pretty scummy
business but it happens to use
blockchain and operating I've also seen
some great implementations of blockchain
for very useful things and so that I
don't think that technology is going
away I don't think it's a Panacea but
then none of them are
right for certain applications of
distributed information where multiple
transactions need to be entered from
multiple sources without a central
Clearinghouse blockchain
but there is just not that many
applications that need that most
organizations as soon as they go we want
some blockchain it's like are you okay
with people putting the transactions in
your system that you don't deal with and
like no we're not it's like okay don't
need blockchain moving on
uh and of course we're living in
Microsoft land so a little bit
about.net.net turn 20 years old in
February this year
.NET Rocks turned 20 years old in August
so we got there I didn't show up to a
couple years later so I haven't been
doing it quite that long but uh
Microsoft's now on a steady Cadence
where they're going to push out a
version of.net every November
for the foreseeable future certainly for
this year for seven and next year for
eight I know he's talking about nine yet
but that also means that they're
slipping features to deliver on time and
you certainly saw this with Maui Maui
was supposed to show up with six and
then they said ah we're not quite ready
here's another Community preview
and then in Spring this year they said
here's some more Community preview I
think Maui really shipped
in August when they did the Maui day
of.net is when we I think we kind of got
to 1.0 which means there were only two
more versions away from this thing being
good
what's Microsoft trying to do here well
this is the unification of all of the
xamls
so
there's more xamls than you knew inside
of Microsoft right Windows had its
literally its own implementation as ammo
that they called uwp and ultimately win
UI then there was the WPF Edition that
lived over in Dev div and then there was
xamarin forms
which now would become my part of
Microsoft as well how are you going to
put all these things together and
ultimately you know xamarin forms was
sort of the low the the smallest set
that you had to build up from but also
was the group with the least amount of
political clout inside of Microsoft so
they really struggled with this but
Maui is actually the success story of
them being able to get win UI and WPF
and xamarin forms rationalize them all
together into a unified xaml stack
that's good news are they solving a
problem we need solved
well yes in the sense of we're still
trying to figure out how to make great
multi-client
the web is one approach to it that's
going to run on your phone and your
tablet and your PC
but that has its own limits
so when we start talking about more
native applications taking advantage of
it do we have a better client choice and
if you listen to.net rocks you know I've
been running the gamut on every Library
I could find I even had the flutter guys
on because I think what they're doing is
pretty cool they've done well enough in
the client in in the mobile space
they're now making a client for Windows
and I thought well we better talk about
that
uh and the same with guys like avalonia
like there's a there's a ton of them and
then for me as someone who gets to
survey the landscape all the time when I
see a fragmentation like this lots of
different libraries working I know this
is an unsolved problem
we're still struggling to say what's the
right way for us to write code once and
run on all the devices
because that's what our customers want
right our customers couldn't care less
what device you wrote it for as long as
it runs on their device
and generally speaking our employers are
not interested in you actually spending
more time and effort to work on more
devices as long as it just works
everywhere the CTO sees it that's the
important part
there is another approach coming from
Microsoft as well if you haven't looked
at it you got to take a look at Power
apps
now I don't like the way they pitch this
product
I think citizen developer is a dumb term
I think it's derogatory actually
I like domain expert
because that's actually what I need and
and I've seen generations of donate
domain experts become developers at
different times throughout software
development right if you go back to the
axis in VB days in the early 90s these
were rapid application tools with
minimal coding initially they eventually
got more complex over time but it was
the same sort of thing you weren't a
real programmer your program VB real
programmers plugin program in C plus
plus and deal with uacs
right you crash when the only way you
know you're really programming is
because Windows keeps crashing excellent
right VB was a way not to crash windows
and still write code and I was a VB
program I switched from MFC to VB in a
second because you know what my
customers like software that works
and I cried all the way to the bank
and I feel the same I look at Power
Platform I go this feels the same thing
that domain experts people who really
understand the business problem can sit
down and build a decent cross-platform
client that works against cloud data
right what the Power Platform has really
done is puts table Stakes on works on
every device uses the cloud as a back
end Microsoft's created a fairly
restrictive licensing model for this is
really only for internal apps because
they charge per seat
and I don't think I would put that on
the public that looks like a good way to
go broke
um
what I find fascinating has been paying
close attention to on the shows is
folks building apps this way also drop
into your normal CI CD pipeline
so their source code gets checked in
they get distributed the same way like
it's just more code being written in a
different way and now they're providing
libraries for us as the as developers to
assist them not only I can put in
back-end apis that it can call but I can
build custom client components that will
work for them as well so we can start
tailoring the ux look we want for all
the powerapps out of our organization by
building custom components for them so
it's not like any of us were getting to
the bottom of our to-do list
right there's so many forms over data
projects that need to be done if someone
is willing to do them that's not me I'm
going to let them do it and probably
help them out as long as we can give
them some guidance that we make testable
software Reliable Software software that
can be updated routinely and be
maintained and these tools can do that
although they are young so far if you
don't care for Power Platform you will
also notice there's a couple of dozen
products like this out there again this
is clearly an unsolved problem but the
forms over data across multiple clients
and clouds is a necessary problem space
that's trying to be solved in a bunch of
ways and so how you write your code
matters for that
uh I talked briefly about containers
just because I think containers have not
gone as far as they can go the idea that
we run code more and more in a
virtualized space just makes sense right
that we get more abstracted from the
hardware we get more abstracted from the
operating system right containers are
virtual machines that have kind of got
the operating system stripped out of it
so you get a little bit smaller but
leaner I think we're going to see more
of this
because we we don't trust software nor
should we we want to be able to put
software in as small a can as possible
with a very specific manifest it says
you are allowed to do X and if you do
anything that's not in this list I will
stop you
and that kind of virtualization is how
we get software to work and play well
with each other we're just not we're not
fully done with this there's more to be
developed here and it's going to affect
how we write software the biggest thing
for me is
are we when we build software how clear
are we on the Manifest side what are
what do we know that our software needs
what libraries are dependent upon what
ports does it depend upon what calling
stocks is it need
so that we could put that into a
document we could put that into into a
manifest of some kind so that something
could enforce all of those rules
if this feels a little overwhelming I
don't blame you
change is hard
but there's more than one way to have a
career often when we first get into
software we're really hooked on the
newest bits and you're ready to jump to
the next stack and like we're all about
the new things and then at some point
that becomes less exciting it's like
really I'm going to reinvent forms over
data again yay
right and it might have been fun the
first few times but it gets less fun
depends on who you are some folks just
dig this they always want to try the
next bits but also you start building up
a repertoire of work you've built a
bunch of stuff for people who want you
to keep taking care of it and that's
okay there's more than one way to have a
career it's pretty normal actually to
hit a point where it's like hey this is
my stack I'm good at this stack and it's
not like your job's gonna disappear as a
technology ages and becomes less of the
Leading Edge project this rate of change
is probably going to decline but it's
utilization doesn't it may not add a lot
of new projects but the existing
projects persisted they need to be cared
for and you are going to have folks that
are jumping off so the pool of
developers gets smaller the man is still
there
and so wages go up
the trick is to be aware of the state of
the industry at the same time and make
sure that stack you're working in how
you solve certain problems right I've
even done a show on how you make web
forms work on a smartphone does it make
it a good idea but you know the point is
there that
as the clients change as as the hardware
evolves and that Hardware is going to be
introduced to the software you're
maintaining do you have an answer do you
know what that looks like and you can
keep being a better and better expert in
a particular stack
or take the ride jump on the new piece
learn again
try something new
you know try and find a Cobalt developer
right now who's able to retire
because they don't turn those machines
off
and they're not making any more Cobalt
developers these days and so I'm talking
to people in their late 60s even in
their 70s making more money than they
ever had before and kind of like I don't
know how I mean I want to retire but
this is really a lot of money
and they're still depending on my code
it's an interesting trap really but it's
one of the things that can happen with
your career is you can choose to go in
that particular direction and say I'm
going to be the specialist in this thing
I found a good place to work they were
going to keep running this software and
I'm going to keep taking care of it for
me or you ride the new bits
let's talk about artificial intelligence
and I use this picture for a very good
reason
the term artificial intelligence is
extremely old it comes from the 1950s
but the first time that most people in
the world heard it was in the movie 2001
A Space Odyssey when it was Hal who then
turned around and tried to kill
everybody so gee I wonder why we have a
weird relationship with artificial
intelligence
uh I like this particular breakdown of
all the different AI umbrella
Technologies one of the things you'll
notice right away is that AI is a
description for technology that does not
work
when it does work it gets a new name
and this the the lines here are kind of
clever you see the shortest line here
with the planning I'll use the clever
pointer here planning scheduling
optimization so that's the technology
that was developed in the 1950s Marvin
Minsky and his folks the first time they
used artificial intelligence and it
actually was part of the scheduling and
optimization systems for the US Military
right that whole you know an army
travels on his stomach thing that's
software written in the 50s that makes
it all work
and then there was an AI winter because
it wasn't you know
uh sentient computers so they happily
bought that part and moved on and in the
1970s we got new this new generation of
Robotics and expert systems
these were the list computers they sold
several thousand of them that were
supposed to be expert systems they hit
their limits another AI winter
and then in the 80s and 90s with the
first generation of speech systems those
are the ones you had to train like
Dragon Naturally Speaking things they
were kind of of machine learning model
but you had to keep repeating phrases so
forth to help educate them to get them
actually work and then in 2011 2012 with
the adversarial uh neural Nets we've got
things like Siri and suddenly you didn't
have to train him anymore they just
worked you know unless you're Australian
and these latest generations of machine
learning Technologies now things like
deep learning particular analytics and
vision systems represent the latest
incarnation of it and if you talk some
of the scientists out there in the in
the in this space are now saying we're
headed into a new AI winter and the rest
of us are just going to work
because you can add these Vision systems
to your software right if there's a
reason to have an image a recognition
system inside your app you can do this
my favorite recognition system because
you know it actually worked perfectly
right
I just this
you know just remind ourselves that
Vision systems have their limits
um so yeah sometimes we need Vision
recognition anybody played with chat
Bots it's hard to call them artificial
intelligence more like artificial
dumbness
uh but
again when we're talking about
automation these days the fact that we
can build up semantic Nets of
information to answer questions and
automatically in some ways build out a
tier one customer support with it if you
work hard at it I also like bots in the
slack channels or in the teams chats for
for passing loan information if we're
doing builds we used to do this with IRC
back in the day I would argue the most
interesting technology just coming down
the pipe recently is this form
recognizer resource system that that
Azure they're building inside of azure
and on the surface you're like okay cool
paper forms scan them but actually break
them down and pre-populate data and so
forth but I took that immediately
several steps first like if you can
recognize a form on paper can you
recognize my forms in my app
because if I wanted to why couldn't I
use the recognizer to rewrite a web
forms app in Power Platform
it's kind of the same thing right just
show me all the versions of the dialogue
snap them all used to recognize you to
break it down show the data chain
generate the app for me
I talk to companies they've got several
thousand custom apps inside of their
organization and they're old and the
people who maintain them are gone
or be ours behind the two Lula still on
the no one get to the bottom of it
modernizing those apps is kind of an
impossible task how much of that could
be automatable
we see machine learning models and being
able to recognize forms forms over data
suddenly becomes an automatic process so
this some of the stuff was literally
announced this week at ignite
and it seems obvious to me that that's
just a normal progression that we these
will just be another set of tools for us
as developers to pull to go together
existing systems take existing workflows
and turn them into new kinds of
automation
if you're into data I mean Predictive
Analytics has been around for decades
maybe longer this idea of okay well I
sold this much last month how much am I
going to sell this month and we've had
lots of of mathematical models for
trying to do those predictions the big
thing that's happened in the past few
years and it continues to go on is that
we now have cloud and tremendous amounts
of compute for this so when when I was
playing around with data analytics in
the 90s that was a Year's worth of
planning to figure out different machine
learning models to build a data
warehouse on millions of dollars worth
of equipment to try and guess the kind
they get the kind of answers that people
wanted then it was very hard to be
responsive to evolving business now I
have cloud and instead of having to
trigger figure out which one of these
different cool analytical approaches I
want to do you just do them all
you got enough compute knock yourself
out and I kind of don't have to build a
warehouse anymore I just store all the
data I've got in a big pile and I sorted
out on demand each time just throw more
compute at it and so
these analytical approaches have gotten
easier and faster and allow us to work
on a larger diversity of data and so
we're taking steps Beyond Predictive
Analytics you start putting machine
learning models into this and you get
more you get better predictions you get
unexpected predictions they're they're
able to test so many variations and look
at Trends pull them out for you and so
these days now you're starting to talk
to folks about prescriptive analytics
and you have experienced
prescriptive analytics so prestigious
analytics goes that extra couple of
steps and says not only what's going to
happen next but
now let's test let's consider all the
possibilities of what could happen next
and then prescribe the one that's most
likely to be beneficial
so think about things like tickle emails
have you noticed these days you throw a
bunch of stuff in a shopping cart and
close the page a little while later get
an email from the site going hey you
left some stuff in the card would you
like a 10 off coupon
do some restrictive analytics no person
looked at that right that's a little
prescriptive analytics looking to see
what's the most likely thing to get you
to buy
now there's a little bit less sort of
gross marketing things you could do here
I've seen
um prescriptive analytics systems used
to figure out when to evacuate
neighborhoods for forest fires because
we know when evacuations kill right it's
that that kind of fright older people
like you're gonna you're gonna cost some
lives or cause some injuries to evacuate
so do you evacuate earlier when it's
under lower stress and maybe they're
just vaguely annoyed by it or do you
wait till later when it has to do more
stress like and there's software now
these predictive models can do
prescriptive determinations to say
here's the chance for the fewest people
to be harmed
right we see the same with maintenance
of equipment you know steam turbines for
power do need maintenance the question
is when do you do it how close do you
get to it failing is it better to
replace Parts earlier when the demand is
lower or wait till failure and swap over
and hope you can get it done before the
next one fails the software tackling all
these problems this is modern data
analytics and it's an interesting space
and it's only growing we're only getting
more sophisticated with it
and you write video games
so the open AI codex where you can
describe a game and it will spit out
code to make a really bad version of
asteroids this is gpt3 and of course
it's not the coolest thing going on with
gpd3 not even close uh copilot's
probably more interesting than that I
imagine some of us have played with this
where years writing comments on code and
it's writing code for you
we just did a show with uh with Michelle
manners who's just out there that
recently published and we were talking
about this is taking our job it's like
not really you're still thinking of what
needs to be built what you're doing is
spending less time wrestling with syntax
right that's what what this tool seems
to be good at you should be able to read
the code it spits out because no
different than cut and pasting from
stack Overflow like you kind of want to
be sure what's going on with that
so it's a it's an interesting tool and
it just speak to a future where more and
more our tools are going to help guide
us to write better quality code
conversations I've had on the show with
guys like mads torgenson were talking
about hey.net's 20 years old how do I
stop writing C sharp like it's 2005
because all those commands still work
and you know we talked about tooling
that we could have tools hinting it's
like hey I get that this is what you
want to do with a string you know you
know look can I do a refactoring for you
to use just some of the features in C
sharp 13. and let me make your code a
bit faster like all those kinds of
optimization and so forth we could have
more machine learning models around all
of that our tools are just going to keep
getting clever they're just going to
help guide us so we spend less time
wrestling with the syntax and more time
solving our customers problems
all right let's have some more fun more
speculation different code we're going
to get to write what replaces the
smartphone the smartphone has clearly
won it is the largest most common
Computing device in the world there are
roughly four billion of them in
operation around the world more or less
one for every adult human
uh we mostly you know torment ourselves
with these things but in more developing
parts of the world this is the
difference between life and death right
this is the thing that actually lets you
know when to plant all right it's your
smart Almanac lets you know how to react
in natural disasters
uh helps you with here with resupplying
water and so forth
these things have been pretty critical
in Ukraine
like we we're all cyborgs right we have
a digital extension to ourselves now
you know it's actually part of your body
right you see upset you get when you
lose it
you know the only reason we don't really
consider ourselves cyborgs is because
it's on the outside
I guess you could put it on the inside
but a gross and and B slows down
upgrades and that's not good
but how do we this phone's been the same
since 2007 more or less it's been a slab
of black gas it gets bigger it's smaller
taller shorter fatter sometimes a full
sometimes it doesn't One camera two
cameras three cameras I saw one with
five cameras I don't need to have many
cameras but okay
the logical thing of course is is
augmented reality this is a mock-up of
what we think Apple's going to make it's
probably not even close it's fake it's a
lie don't look at it too long here's a
real one this is the Qualcomm xr1 so
again a pedagogue goggles with some
sensors on the front Tethered to an
Android phone
probably a bit more proud to reduce the
weight on the face phones in the back
pocket you've got a wire going to it you
can buy these today they're about a
thousand dollars if you want something
that looks more like Google Glass this
is the Toshiba unit it's the Dyna Edge
again the future is here it's just not
evenly distributed right so we've got
these devices out there and we're
starting to experiment them with certain
environments and of course I'd be remiss
if I didn't talk a little bit about
hololens
all augmented reality devices different
from virtual reality devices so
something you look through that's also
looking out at what you're looking at
and adding information to you so typical
application and these are real
applications today are in the industrial
area so when you're working on very
expensive Machinery that you have to do
things correctly and safely the fact
that these glasses and their ability to
see what you're doing create a detailed
document of the process they can
actually give you the checklist in place
so you're not looking down at other
documents they're actually marking as
you finish each step before they present
the next one and they give you an
ability to request an expert while
you're working on something to help to
be able to see through your glasses and
add information help you do more
I look at these devices right now
because they're stunningly complicated
machines right the hololens 2 is a
complete computer battery pack on your
head it's pretty well balanced it's also
3 500 US dollars
and so it's not a consumer device it's
an industrial device and as an
industrial device that means it also
runs about
a thousand dollars a month in iot costs
when we've we've got the field projects
out there now it costs a lot to operate
these things
anybody remember the Blackberry
the foam with the keyboard on it now you
probably remember the later versions but
the original version of the 1990s the
only way you could make that thing work
is if you ran a custom Exchange Server
installation in your in your company you
had to load on the BlackBerry Enterprise
servers and so forth so you need a
couple of guys a white lab coats just to
keep that stuff alive and then these
phones were like a thousand dollars a
piece but you had email on your phone
let me say that again email on your
phone
in like 1998
okay now 10 years later that wouldn't be
a big deal but at the time it was huge
that's exactly what these devices feel
like right now they are expensive
they're they need a lot of
infrastructure to operate on and so only
certain companies are making it make
sense so if you're maintaining a 50
million dollar steam turbine
Thirty a five thousand dollar headset
that costs a thousand dollars a month to
operate not a big deal
you're probably not going to play Candy
Crush on it
uh what does the consumer version of
this look like don't know yet but it can
do everything the phone can do and more
right it opens the door to a different
level of communication and access the
the whole camera on your face thing
we'll get over that
even if they look vaguely ridiculous
we'll get over that too because this is
also vaguely ridiculous it's just this
became socially acceptable once the
device was good enough
right once upon a time when you're
carrying a smartphone around in 2001
you were pretty dorky
when the iPhone came along was so good
that we needed somebody else said hey
can I try that you couldn't get it back
from
so I own a Google Glass
when I wore it out in public and I
really did
the normal thing people said was can I
try it
then when they found it not compelling
they made fun of it
okay once the device is compelling
enough the social contract will change
so let's talk about meta oh meta
how do you turn a multi-billion dollar
organization into a smaller
multi-billion dollar organization
so let's face it Facebook was up against
it right with my Apple locking down on
Advertising so forth Facebook business
model was already being disrupted you
can't blame the Zuck for trying to Pivot
he also did does own Oculus and so he
had the VR headsets he's got to do
something so he goes all in on meta the
problem is it's Facebook
and you can't start with social media
you actually have to do something useful
first
right I don't even think he knows why
Facebook was ultimately successful but
we've forgotten how how much Facebook
changed over the years from the early
odds you know for a while there it was a
college thing they remember there was
like the gaining wave it was all about
playing games on it and it became your
your community bulletin board now it's
just like a bad tick tock impersonator
but we got these headsets and literally
this week they announced the pro so the
Quest 2 easily the best VR headset
especially for only about 400 US dollars
is a really decent price now they've
just put out this Pro it's 1500 so I
don't know who the heck's gonna buy it
the main change they did was they
balanced it better so instead of just
being a pair of goggles and straps the
batteries on the back so it sits more
comfortable in your head but it is also
heavier than the Quest 2 but inside of
it are sensors for your face so you now
have facial expressions because it's
looking at the Expressions you make
inside your glasses because what you
really want to do is feed Facebook your
facial expression data
now Microsoft just announced teaming up
with them to do the Microsoft teams in
VR implementation against this gear my
thinking is they know that what meta's
building isn't going very well Horizon
world is so bad that not even the people
that work on Horizon world are spending
time in Horizon world
but there's also the Horizon workplace
and that's that VR workplace idea and
now they're going to work with Microsoft
so Microsoft has access to this Hardware
so we could be doing teams meetings in
VR I don't know that it makes me happy
now it's just screens really really
close to my eyes but it is an
advancement and these AR systems and VR
systems are all programmed largely the
same way
if you like C sharp learn Unity you can
program a quest with that and a hololens
for that matter
uh or the Unreal Engine if you like
working a little more low level and
there's other native Solutions as well
but for us in in our world
Unity is a good solution to that and
it's in not just for making games it's
going to be about the VR space I think
what the metaphors needs is real work I
I presume collaboration may be enough
but I'm still thinking about like
reporting visualizations those hard
analytics you know when you you get to a
point where you your screen's just not
big enough for the analysis you're doing
like is there a three-dimensional way to
do that that would be a better way to to
Pat to pursue an intuition about data I
don't know so best idea I have so far
but that's what's actually going to
establish this product is in the
Enterprise that kind of money it makes
sense if it gives a competitive
advantage
I just don't think that
the Monday morning stand up in VR with
facial expressions
so it's like wow I like the new headsets
now everybody looks sleepy
one last bit and that is quantum
Computing by requests so Quantum
Computing has actually made real
progress It's Not Just fictional it's
it's not far from done this is a very
challenging problem in order to have
reliable Quantum states you have to
build a computer that essentially is
submerged in liquid helium liquid helium
is not fun to work with it's so cold
that you actually have to pre-cool the
parts with liquid nitrogen first before
you pop the liquid helium in or you have
a helium explosion and in fact if you
want to have a quantum computer one of
the things you have to build into the
structure is a venting system for a
helium
and so you'll if you lose control of the
and it starts to overheat you have to be
able to vent it out of the building
safely it's not a trivial thing to
operate a quantum computer
uh over the past few years we've had a
few interesting steps in quantum
computers this is a picture of the
Google Sycamore which is Google's best
effort in 2019 they had a 54 Cubit
version of the Sycamore that did a test
with 53 qubits because apparently one of
them was broken
using this thing called uh
superconducting transmon Cubit
entanglement
and they ran on a problem that for about
200 seconds that uh was a random
generator problem
and this is where they showed what they
called Quantum Computing Advantage they
said this would take 10 000 years in a
conventional computer
uh their Rivals IBM then produced a
result that produced the same result in
two and a half days with a conventional
computer but that's still two and a half
days versus 200 seconds although the
taoi light supercomputer in China then
ran in a solution that took 300 seconds
so there's an interesting aspect of this
whole Quantum competition is you've got
a few different companies trying to
build better and better quantum
computers and Publishing the results and
you also have the class computers people
try to redo those same models and it's
forcing them all to get better it
reminds me of when like
uh Internet Explorer and chrome and
Firefox were all dueling for better
JavaScript rendering engines and it made
us all better Quantum seems to be in
that particular state right now there's
a bunch of different companies trying to
get better
uh in China the uh the xujang photonic
quantum computer about 113 cubits did a
200 second run of uh boson sampling
model using Quantum computation I
figured this would be about two and a
half billion years of classical
Computing nobody's really challenged
that I really appreciate this particular
run because totally different quantum
computer design not even remotely
similar photonic Quantum is complex
and over on the IBM land with their
transbond architecture using a thing
called get this transmission line
shunted plasma oscillation qubits they
have 127 qubit uh processor that started
running last year the tests have the
test results have not been published I
was searching for them again today so I
suspect it didn't go well
because generally if the results are
good then you publish them and then they
get challenged and you go around so IBM
had this road map with this 128 Cubit
processor called the eagle that was
going to be followed up this year with
the Osprey with 433 qubits no sign of it
and then next year a thousand qubits in
a processor called Condor so I think
they're kind of up against the wall or
having some challenges but that's to be
expected you're doing original research
and I'd be remiss if I didn't mention
uh yeah unsw here in Sydney they've had
a bunch of major Quantum breakthroughs
here they're not making processors but
they are dealing with some of the
problems in Quantum computing
so dealing with qubit stability
stabilization entanglement Solutions
coherency Solutions pretty cool stuff
and I think it's uh it's great to see
this cooperation going on the real
question is what the heck do you do with
quantum computers like well how would
you do anything useful for them like
what's the problem you're not going to
play Candy Crush on them so what are
they for
and typically the most common problems
like you usually hear about if you well
in the news you'll hear about oh they're
going to destroy encryption
right which is not a very interesting
statement yes eventually when we have
million qubit
quantum computers will be able to
decrypt 4096 RSA very easily and there
is a conversation going on right now
that's saying hey if Bad actors are
siphoning up your encrypted data they
could be grabbing all of that so they
can decrypt it later when these machines
come available however long that may
take but that's not saving the world
it's not making a huge difference the
interesting space for quantum computers
is actually quantum chemistry so if we
think about agriculture we learned
thousands of years ago to rotate crops
that you grew wheat on a given piece of
land and the next season you tried to
grow it again it didn't grow as well you
depleted the soil of some resources and
so you'd switch the crop instead of
planting wheat then you then plant beans
the beans actually would put stuff back
into the soil you'd pick the beans plow
the plow the plants under then let it
fallow for a year and then you could
plant wheat again it would keep going
crop rotation we don't do that anymore
because somewhere around World War II we
came up with the Haber Bosch process the
Haber Bosch process was a way to make
ammonia at scale now they developed that
during World War one because they needed
to make bombs turns out the same stuff
that makes fertilizer makes bombs too so
thank you there you go for the military
but the reality is this helps spark the
Green Revolution after World War one
with artificial fertilizers and modern
planting techniques and new new seeds we
were able to grow the world population
from barely over a billion to 3 billion
in a matter of three or four decades
it's an astonishing achievement For
Better or Worse we've only doubled since
then and it's because we're able to feed
everybody by doing this making lots of
fertilizer it has consequences it's also
one percent of all our power consumption
is making fertilizers and distributing
them onto plants and yet the bean plant
does the same thing there's a rhizome on
the roots of the bean plant
um that has inside of it an enzyme
called nitrogenase and nitrogenase is
able to affix
nitrogen and hydrogen together to make
ammonia
in the root of a bean plant
you know not a lot of turbines and high
pressure energy going on in there now
we've studied this particular enzyme for
more than 100 years and we know that
there are iron atoms and malignant atoms
involved in a catalytic reaction that
puts the nitrogen and hydrogen together
to make ammonia we just don't know how
it works and the computational model
trying to figure that out is too
complicated for classical Peters there's
too many electrons and vaults it's a 2
to the 170th complex problem
this should be solvable by something
along the lines of a 500 qubit
supercomput quantum computer depending
on the particular style in a few minutes
now what would that mean if we solve
that problem we mean we've now on we now
know what the catalytic reaction is that
makes that nitrogenous enzyme work so
could we then recreate it in the lab
instead of doing it plant we do it with
a device of some kind
the chemical reaction so that we now
have a low energy way to make
fertilizers
so I start to immediately go to the idea
of at an individual plant you have a
little stake stuck in the ground that
runs on a watch battery it gets this
nitrogen from its from the air the
hydrogen from water and it just puts as
much fertilizer as that plant needs at
the time
so we reduce the energy impact of doing
fertilization and get more precise with
it
that's one
Battery Technology
is essentially Alchemy we just what
we've gotten really good is mixing
different compounds together and then
testing rapidly to see if we can make a
better battery and we have gotten better
but we don't really actually understand
how batteries work it's too complex of
an electron exchange problem that's a
Quantum Computing problem
superconductors we have a new generation
of superconductors really developed in
the 1980s the rare earth barium cubic
oxide superconductors we know it's a
it's a phase state of matter but we
really don't know why it works it's too
complex of an electron compute problem
that's another one there's about 300 of
these
that each one if we understood them well
enough using a quantum computer
we could make a difference in make a
better battery make make a better
superconductor one that could run at
room temperature doesn't need to be
cooled by anything all sorts of
solutions like this better Fabrics that
better medicines all from being able to
do the sophisticated kind of compute but
they're all also deterministic problems
like once you've solved it you kind of
need to solve it again I'm really busy
chasing around what's the quantum
Computing problem that's
non-deterministic we'd have to do over
and over and over that we need to keep
going because maybe we only need a
handful of these quantum computers right
that's an old quote from IBM from Thomas
Watson it's actually apocryphaly didn't
really say it this way but he said you
know maybe there's only a market for
five computers of course that at the
time when he was saying that the
computer looked like this
right it is hard
to think you know when you need rooms
dedicated to the machine
how many of these do you really need and
I kind of feel that way about quantum
computers I've already described how
complicated they are and how fragile
they are how many are really going to
need especially if you're only working
on a determinant is a problem it's very
hard to look at this
and see this
it's tough right you can't it's hard to
predict that we don't know what a St
what a reliable large-scale quantum
computer to do for us Beyond this Fair
set of problems but we've seen that
before
and that leads me to a story about
William Shockley William Shockley was
one of three men who developed the
original geranium transistor this is a
picture of that original transistor
and Shockley went on to create the
Silicon Valley he created a company
called Shockley semiconductors
and in Palo Alto because that's where
his mother lived and begin the beginning
of Silicon Valley and fair child
semiconductor he went from these
original simple transistors to substrate
based semiconductors
now he was struggling to actually
understand all of the chemistry problems
and so he
he needed a computer now this is before
the Silicon computer existed before the
CPU had been made but there were
computers back then they just you know
looked like this
they were mechanical computers their
bits were stored in Ferris cores or in
vacuum tubes or in relays they were
computers they were a long way from that
silicon substrate that would build these
really dense little computers and yet he
used those primitive computers to model
how the Silicon substrate would work and
it worked and he built some of the first
semiconductors ever made and led to
everything that's happened here
and maybe that's what's going to happen
with quantum computers that these
unreliable fragile complicated quantum
computers will be the devices we need to
build a reliable simple qubit that
allows us to use them in many different
ways I don't know what that looks like
that's too far in the future for me but
I do know this
it's up to us
to decide what any of that looks like
what's next is what we do we make the
future and we can choose what the future
we want all of us in this room we have
those skills in different forms there's
just stories to be told and work to be
done thanks for your time
[Applause]